qu'est ce qui se passe c'est tout alors
lui parce que le nôtre huit ans au cou
au bâton il tangue parce que c'est un
bateau senneurs je pensais que j'allais
mal de vin blanc doux
[Musique]
pour aller découvrir un nouveau produit
de motorola juste là derrière cette
jolie petite péniche
regardez là vous allez le truc qui
flottent enroulé le drapeau le flag
c'est la péniche of de niche très sympa
on est bien en bord de seine pour parler
justement 2 motorola motorola qui
revient dans la partie que tu reviens
dans game comme on dit avec une gamme
complète j'ai déjà parlé du motorola one
n'en parle du motorola onevision une
offre qui est sympa dans le milieu de
gamme notamment avec un gros focus sur
la photo sont ça plutôt intéressant vous
emmène
on va pas les enfants
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle de motorola du
motorola one vie jeune qui vient d'être
présenté à l'instant sur une péniche
juste derrière moi c'est ce smartphone
alors là j'ai la version de yann version
un peu plus marron mais ça c'est la
version saphir et la diversion c'est la
version vous dit pas de bêtise j'ai pris
mes notes comme d'habitude vous vous en
douterez et l'autre version c'est la
version bronze alors un smartphone qui
est intéressant on est dans le milieu de
gamme motorola reprend des forces
motorola est revigoré revient avec un
smartphone intéressant il faut un gros
focus dans le milieu de gamme sur la
photo c'est vraiment un axe qui marche
très bien pour le smartphone est là très
clairement motorola cherche à venir
draguer plus des clients qui veulent de
bonnes photos dans le milieu de gamme
tarifs vraiment très intéressant et
c'est ce qu'ils font avec ce smartphone
alors ce qu'on nous propose déjà le
premier point qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est le format 21/9 c'est
un écran full hd + 6,3 pouces et un
écran lcd qui dans l'absolu comme ça en
le découvrant on testera dans quelques
jours donc vous dès maintenant vous
abonner mais comme ça a l'air sympa moi
j'aime bien ses formes avec ses écrans
batteur 9e c'est une sony disposition
dessus notamment avec l'xperia one c'est
vraiment le format cinémascope format
très allongée et vous avez des films
dédiés sur netflix
avec ce format qui est bien c'est
vraiment le format cinéma de base c'est
vraiment hyper bien très pratique très
sympa pour au gré des films dont conseil
fera ce côté cinéma en fait c'est le
format d'un iphone 10 s plus haut plus
long pourquoi pas il se tient assez bien
d'une main on le verra également au
total c'était très très prochainement
donc ça c'est la première promesse c'est
le côté écran on a une résolution fhd
plus plutôt cool plutôt sympa ça c'est
le premier point c'est vraiment bien en
termes de performance ou les annonces
effectivement un processeur oak d'accord
on nous en parle pas trop plus
est-ce que c'est d'une médiathèque est
ce que c'est du qualcomm pour l'instant
je ne sais pas on en reparlera très très
très prochainement
on a 4 gigas de ram 128 giga de stockage
en nuage est fait cela devrait alès vite
assez tranquille bien évidemment j'en
dirai plus très très prochainement se
testera on a une batterie de trois mille
cinq cents millions perreur motorola
lance une autonomie d'une journée et en
un quart d'heure grâce à la recharge
rapide 15 droite vous allez pouvoir lui
mettre 7 heures d'autonomie
les nouveaux viennent avant vous et
cette petite encoche avec cette caméra
là bon on est dans le format qui se fait
depuis le début de l'année 2019 rien de
bien étonnant plutôt bien plutôt bien
intégré vous avez la prise jack sur le
dessus le petit micro réduction de bruit
sur le côté le bouton de volume bouton
pour allumer pour l'éteindre petit haut
parleur mono le micro la recharge en usb
tilt c'est ici le tiroir de cartes sim
la prise en main elle est vraiment très
très sympa à l'arrière vous avez un dock
4d avec des petits eiffel rien n'est
fait incurvé là c'est plus foncé au
milieu plus clair sur le côté des
passants s'en rend bien compte parce que
là l'éclairage est pas hyper optimale il
est quelque chose comme 20h30 la
présentation mais d'avoir lieu donc on
sera pas forcément hyper bien bien
content comme ça il ya un côté très
sympa
vous avez le capteur d'empreinte
digitale au milieu qui est brand des
motorola a déjoué mais comme ça en plein
centre c'est pas mal double module photo
on a une caméra principale de 48
mégapixels la deuxième je n'ai pas eu
d'infos dessus elle doit vraiment venir
pour renforts dont peut-être une 2
mégapixels à 5 mégapixels maximum
qu'elle a pour les traits le bouquet
pour le mode portrait pas plus je sais
pas pareil hein la caméra 48e mégapixels
je sais pas si c'est la sony mx à 186,6
milles sur les caméras de samsung on a
dit comme ils l'ont pas ils seraient
plus à samsung ça évidemment on le saura
un peu plus tard elle reçoit paraît bien
évidemment lors du test
avec la techno 4 pics allant dans l'idée
de la techno cap excellence ça va
prendre 4 pixels sont offerts un sol
mais micro pixel pour capter plus de
lumière et vous sentir dès photo de 12
mégapixels complètement optimisé
ils ont vraiment fait un gros focus sur
l'appareil photo de nuit également à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de 25 méga
pixels avec la fameuse techno 4 pixels
en un qui vous permettra d'avoir des
photos optimisé en aura moins de pixels
mais une meilleure lumière pas tout
avoir pour ça on se teste aura très très
prochainement comme ça je vous dirai
tout pillé une vraie optimisation
logiciel derrière avec de l'intelligence
artificielle pour la reconnaissance de
scène pour avoir des meilleurs modes
portrait et puisqu'il ne sait quand est
ce que vous allez ajouter une personne
servira cette salle nous paraît optimisé
pour le mode portrait switcher en mode
portrait de sap est aussi intéressante
si vous avez de la reconnaissance de
scène optimiser les couleurs les
éclairages enfin il ya pas mal de
petites choses derrière ça peut paraître
assez intéressant d'un point de vue
logiciel tout cas le boulot qui a été
fait derrière par motorola et tourne sur
un android one avec 3 ans minimum deux
mises à jour de sécurité donc ça c'est
pareil voudrais tu aimes relativement
tranquille l'appareil photo 40 et mia
pixels ouvre à f un point c'est tout et
surtout vous avez une stabilisation
optique ça c'est cool et ça peut vous
rattraper dès fois les clichés surtout
en mode nuit il n'y a pas trop de
lumière peut vous sauver la vie se
permettrait en tout cas de voir des
clichés optimiser une optimisation six
logiciels pour le mode portrait pour
revenir
avoir un bon détourage après vous m
différents effets derrière en fonction
des choix que vous pourrez faire vous
verrez ça va être en tous cas c'est
intéressant sur le papier on l'a déjà vu
sur d'autres smartphones des petits
gadgets mais bon pourquoi pas sa patte
rigolo vous avez toujours le mode cinéma
graff le filtre couleurs tous en
reprendra d'ici au comptant et testé et
c'est un smartphone qui dispose dans
deux couleurs en marron et en bleu au
tarif de 319 euros 99 alors vous avez
une offre de pré lancement jusqu'au 1er
juin vous avez les bugs qui sont offerts
et les petits bugs non vous les trouvez
au tarif de 129 euros 99 fouillé mais la
prima leçon j'ai tout noté là-dessus et
c'est ailleurs si ce smartphone vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description qu'ils ont trouvé
dans toutes les bonnes crémeries 4 s'est
abîmé la crevette cru que tu bois toi
ce match maillot rose et monsieur très
bon choix madame peu d'hésitation
moisson d'été et vous qu'est ce que vous
voulez monsieur je ne vois pas je mange
jusqu après avoir bu il faut manger ils
vivent et du vin blanc ah oui d'accord
après un burrito vergézois convoi
guillaume écoute moi je suis un peu déçu
parce que steven rend vachement mieux à
l'écran que moi il dit vachement plus de
merde que moi qu'est ce qui se passe est
toujours seul en luge parce que le mot
twitter bateau qui tangue parce que
c'est un pathos et médecine
je pensais que gérald maillot de bain
blanc du temple bateau tente vraiment
comique et rouge je trouve que la côte
est c'est roland garros s'est bien battu
nadal
voilà il pas ce que vous en pensez
comment vous le trouvez ce smartphone
bien oui non intéressant pas du tout
pourquoi je laime un peu beaucoup à la
folie passionnément pas du tout vous
marquez tout ça moi je trouve que ces
propos intéressants tt ce qui est cool
c'est qu'un acteur comme motorola qui
est très longtemps qui est des périodes
très difficiles là revient revient dans
la partie avec une vraie belle repris sa
part les trades faire des
investissements d'être plus présent sur
le marché de proposer plus de modèles ça
c'est cool
motorola s'est aussi les nouveaux lieux
nouveaux qui a présenté un ordinateur un
call écran pliable donc on va kaeppelin
de technos ça avance intéressant ça
c'est cool il pas ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire et puis n'oubliez
pas si vous intéresse vous avez le lien
il pas de vous abonner comme ça vous
saurez tout vous suivrez tout à bientôt
tiens